e
e e
put my microphone on just so everybody
can hear
everything and as I understand this
session will be uh
recorded so the reason why I asked you
all here this
morning is we have before us um the the
Bill uh 1685 which is uh a bill that had
some uh redefining Homestead Foods as
Artisan foods and whole bunch of other
legislation behind that and this bill
was um voted interim study by the house
and by our committee because we felt
that um the legislation that was
presented to us
was first of all very complicated
and uh really needed to be looked at and
compared to uh current law please take a
seat along the table here because I'd
like this to be somewhat
informal what we have before us is for
this subcommittee to to um discuss this
legislation and some of the what we have
get an understanding of what our
licensing looks like like now and what
stakeholders and people who are doing
food production locally would what kinds
of changes they would like to see to
this
um the committee as a whole environment
and agriculture will be T we have three
interim study bills before us this is
one of them and we will then have to
make the recommendation as to whether or
not the legislation being considered
should be recommended for future
legislation or not recommended for
future
legislation it's my belief
that we probably in our discussions of
this bill and I've heard so many people
interested in doing
something uh to expand our um local food
production abilities for our farmers and
other local food producers it's like
likely that I would imagine our
committee would recommend this for
future
legislation but I'm not going to make
that determination on my own nor um um I
don't know that the four of us will make
that decision today either um so I just
want to open up the discussion about
this bill the concept of this bill why
why was this bill brought forward what
kind of um problem does this kind of
legislation seek to
solve and temper that with um what kinds
of laws we already have in statute
regarding licensing regarding food
production and managing the risk of
foodborn
illness um so I'm gonna I'm going to
start this off with um the folks from uh
Department of Health and Human Services
to describe to us what the homestead
food operation
licensing uh landscape looks like what
why we do what we do and uh I'll have it
from there and I guess uh we have
Colleen Smith from Department of Health
and Human Services to uh give us that
presentation after that I would like to
have the the bill sponsor come and well
talk about and you can sit and play
place as well talk about
um why you brought this bill forward
what are the the aspects of this bill
that you feel are
important and what are the the types of
problems that you seek to
solve with the legislation that you
brought
forward so I'll go ahead and um
let Colleen Smith uh give us a an
overview of of what's going on with our
licensing and food prod local food
production you have the mic is it
on there you are R red it's got to be
red there we go is that okay does that
work I think so good morning my name is
Colleen Smith I'm with the Department of
Health and Human Services I'm I was
formerly with the food prot food
protection section I'm now transition
into a new role um with our Bureau of
Infectious Disease Control but um
certainly um I've been with the food
protection section for over 16 years and
have a lot of um working knowledge over
the years of what what where our current
Homestead food operation licensing
stands and um some also some perspective
of history of of how we how we um got to
where we are now with food protection
licensing and I also have Erica Davis
she's with the food Protection Program
she's with me to um co-present and
answer questions as they as they come up
and please feel free um as
representative Aaron said that this is
very informal um I'm going to my attempt
is to give an overview of our current
laws on Homestead food operations but
I'm certainly happy to pause and answer
any questions that come up as as we go
through this okay thank you um ma'am
we'd like you to join us up here yeah
sure
thank you for coming
today
proceed so we'll start with the
homestead food operation definition so
by Statute in RSA 143a colon 12 a
homestead food operation is a person who
produces Homestead food products
excluding potentially hazardous food so
these are foods that require temperature
control for safety and it's only in that
person's home kitchen of their primary
residence in New Hampshire so we have
home kitchen means their home kitchen it
doesn't mean a garage it doesn't mean a
basement it's it's we it's limited to
your home kitchen is that excuse me um
when you say that's limited to the home
kitchen is that actually specified in
statute or is that in a rule so this
this is the definition from the statute
home K it says home kitchen and so
that's what we have always um put the
guard rails around a home kitchen a home
kitchen doesn't mean other areas of of a
person's residence it's it's the home
kitchen and I believe this was founded
in that it was it was meant to give
people an opportunity to start small in
their home kitchen but the expectation
is you're using residential equipment
you're using a residential refer Ator a
stove it wasn't meant to I'm going to
expand and put in commercial um ovens
and things like that in my basement or
out building or so forth and we do have
people that do that but they're licensed
as a commercial kitchen in that instance
it's not a home it's not a homestead
food operation yeah representative
ktoa thank you madam chair and thank you
for taking my
question if I heard you correctly you
said potentially hazardous food mean
means food that needs to be controlled
by temperature
correct and that's it or and it also
includes low low acid foods okay thank
you
sure go
ahead so in New Hampshire we have two
types of Homestead operations those that
are exempt from food lure and those that
require by Statute a homestead food
license so those that are exempt it's
purely B based on where they're offering
the product it's not we don't have any
income limitations at one point in time
there was a an income limitation that
required you to be licensed or not
licensed it there was also um it it it's
Pur it's it doesn't they can only make
the same types of products those that
don't require temperature control for
safety the non potentially hazardous
foods but depending on where you're
selling it that's what determines
whether or not you need the license so
those that are exempt from a homestead
license are those that are selling it
from their own residents their own Farm
Stand or from a farmers's market or
actually and I'm sorry and I this is
there's an error in here and or retail
food stores that was something that
changed um in the last few years that
they can also sell at retail
stores um if you want to sell to
restaurants over the Internet or to
wholesalers Brokers or other food
Distributors that's when you have to um
apply for a license and currently we
have 149 lenses it's a it's a $150
annual Food Service license and again um
we we just as we do um inspections for
any other license facilities there is a
a inspection that's part of that um
these are scheduled inspections because
it's person's home we can't we can't
just show up randomly at a person's home
and not knowing if they're going to be
producing food so any Homestead food
inspections are they are scheduled and
and actually it's um we we welcome this
opportunity because it's a time for us
to have a one-on-one with the producer
to get any questions answered that they
might have whether it's about labeling
whether it's about um their food storage
it's a it's a very it um it's it's a
very I think educational inspection it's
not uh we're trying to help those folks
make the food in a safe way
sure uh representative kto has a
question uh thank you madam chair uh
again thank you I just want to go back
to retail food establishments did you
say that they can you can now sell with
just the homestead food or do you have
to be licensed so if they want to sell
to a retail food store that is allowable
under an exempt food food license okay
so looking at your slide yeah sorry um
we could cross off other retail food
establishments and move that up to the
exemption yes thank
you yeah um you have a question ma'am
can you please uh say your name and
where you're
from zos and I'm from Dunbarton um and I
had a question about something you
mentioned at the beginning um when you
said that kitchen the kitchen being in
the kitchen is by Statute and I was
wondering if you could clarify if that's
the revised statutes or if that's the
administrative code
so that's an the actual RSA 143 d a
colon 12 okay
thanks thank
you so the foods that are allowed to be
made in a home food operation Homestead
food operation and again these are it's
it's all the same types of products
whether you require a license or you
don't require license so these include
bake items such as breads rolls cookies
muffins brownies cakes double crusted
fruit pies candies fudge um baked dry
products herbs spices Etc um acid foods
including vinegars
and uh mustards and then we recently
added processed acidified foods in the
last legislative session including
pickles and Salsas and of course jams
and jellies those have always been
allowed to be made um the because of the
the high sugar content in and the the
low PH make them a safer product to be
made in a home
kitchen the types of prodcts that are
not allowed um so the the term
potentially hazardous that's it's that's
that term is is a it's a pretty um it's
an older term um the the more modern
turn term is called TCS food or it's
Foods requiring temperature control for
safety so and also low acid foods are
not allowed to be made in a homestead
food operation so examples of the foods
that are not allowed currently are fresh
or frozen soups cheesecakes hummus and
other dips salads sandwiches and canned
green beans would be an example of a low
acid food and that is certainly because
of because um an item like a green bean
it's it's um acidity can lend to if not
processed correctly could lend to the
risk of claustrum botulinum if there if
it was processed incorrectly and so that
because of there's a high risk with
processing low acid foods could be
things like pumpkin butter um the things
that are generally um not high in acid
so not like your fruits um that are in
jams and jellies these are currently not
allowed to be made in a homestead food
operation in order to make these types
of products you would need to have a
commercial kitchen to do this and we've
offered that there are there are certain
um facilities in New Hampshire that rent
space for for small food producers there
our businesses that their sole business
is to do this activity or also we've
also had instances where someone might
have a relationship with um like a local
pizza shop that opens at in the
afternoon they can come in in the
morning and use their commercial
facility their their sinks their
Refrigeration Etc to do their their food
production whether they're a caterer
that's making
um sandwiches and salads Etc or doing
pro low acid
processing so as I mentioned before um
the a homestead food operation is
restricted to doing food preparation in
their home kitchen we don't require the
the same standards for physical
facilities that are other licensed
establishments like restaurants grocery
stores are held to where by commercial
kitchen is not required there's no
requirement for a three compartment sink
they're allowed to use their a two Bas
sink or one Bay sink and a dishwasher
for their wear washing um we don't have
the the same Plumbing requirements for
an indirect waistline for sinks pets are
allowed to be in the homestead they just
have to be excluded from the kitchen
prior to
production and the products are required
to be labeled that they're made in a
residential kitchen either um they're
exempt from a license or they're
licensed as as applicable to the
particular
instance
so yeah a question from representative
com thank you sorry about this um it
says there's no requirement for a three
compartment sink is a single sink
acceptable or do they need a double sink
so we have allowed them to use a single
sink and a dishwasher or a two or 2bay
sink for wear washing thank you
sure so I know there have been some
there's been some confusion about other
types of exemptions so I'm just going to
um take a a quite a little quick
deviation to the other types of
establishments that are exempt from a
license uh these are occasional Food
Service establishment occasional Food
Service events and temporary food
establishments so these are exempt by
Statute from a food service license so
the occasional Food Service
establishment is any food establishment
where food served or provided for the
public on premises of the establishment
whether or not there's a charge no more
than 40 days in a 30-day period And so
um an example of this would be um a a a
vendor at a farmer's market who might be
preparing on site sandwiches or sausages
or or other prepared foods they can they
could go to One farmers's Market a week
prepare food on site and not be required
to have a license based on this
statute so is this actually in statute
or is this a rule this is in statute
okay so occasional food service is
defined in statute and ex exempt from a
license in
statute so we also have what's called
occasional Food Service events and these
are events that are not regularly
scheduled this could be something like a
homecoming barbecue a a fireman's um
chicken dinner these are things that are
not regularly scheduled they happen um
irregularly and they are not required to
be licensed as
well question from representative comto
and then thank you madam chair and thank
you again are there any foods that are
exempt from these uh from being
um used from these occasional Food
Service establishments or sold or given
out so it these are these can be a
challenge because we don't have any
there's no regul they're not required to
be licensed or inspected so there's no
regulatory oversight over these types of
venues so we we have recommendations on
our website that are posted for
occasional Food Services or those that
are exempt from a license but but we
don't have any enforcement over these
these items thank you okay and you have
a question
representative hward I'm sorry thank you
madam chair um Miss Smith so under an
occasional Food Service event that would
include Church bake sales yes um
Community dinners old home Day events
um farmers markets that are sponsored by
municipalities private
Enterprises for example well I think I
think that's um my the farmers's market
depending on if that gets into that Reg
again these are not regularly scheduled
events so if you have a farmers market
that's every T every Tuesday um from 2:
to 4: that's a regularly scheduled event
that doesn't fall under that occasional
um Food Service
event okay thank you representative ktoa
thank you madam chair I'd like to follow
up on something um where with representa
Elward um so what your saying is an
occasional Food Service event so like a
farmers market that's scheduled every
Saturday would not be occasional what if
there was a breakfast scheduled every
month just at a certain on at a certain
venue is would that be considered an
occasional or would they then need a
commercial kitchen so likely you also so
and this is where I I perfectly um agree
that there's confusion over this because
you also have your occasional Food
Service establishment so so those could
be considered a a church a church
breakfast that happens every Sunday four
days in a month we I know some Sundays
some some mons have five Sundays we we
uh for the purposes of this we we're not
going to require a license in that
instance so and I think to be I don't
these these um exemptions have been in
place for many many years prior to I've
been with the department since 2008
they've been there since then I I think
they probably were founded in having
this abil AB ility not to definitely
also being cognizant of the Department's
resources that um there there's many
many many of these happening every every
weekend every day across New Hampshire
so um looking at not necessarily that
the admitting that there's not high-risk
foods but because of the frequency that
there that they have been allowed to
offer that's one of the reasons why I
think I I I would say is probably
there's no licensing requirements
so my question then is why wouldn't a
farmer's market be included in
occasional Food
Service I mean they they don't don't
meet all year round normally it's just
the summer months once a
week so so I think it's it's a matter of
looking at the farmers market itself
isn't isn't serving food you have
individual operators within the farmers
market that are providing food that are
providing
food
okay yeah representative Elward and and
then I'm sorry Addie okay thank you
thank you madam chair for taking my
question Miss Smith you um responded to
a public record request by the
researcher for this committee and
submitted um information uh on January
31st regarding um statistics from your
department are you familiar with this
report food foodborn
illnesses I I I I do remember the
request but I I guess I would have to be
have it in front of me it was a few
months ago to know exactly what the of
the request was and um in it it
says of all the
complaints um your department handled
over five years only three in involve
Community Gatherings soup kitchens or
other unregulated or uninspected
facilities I just want to see if you can
confirm that's your understanding of
complaints regarding food board and
illness so this would be Consumer
complaint correct yeah that sounds that
sounds over five years okay thank
you and uh Addie go back to the
definition of the occasional Food
Service establishment um so you that
people at farmers markets can serve food
that's time temperature controlled for
safety my understanding of that statute
was that it was only applicable to um
people who are serving food from the
premises where it was prepared and I was
wondering if you could explain kind of
how that fits into the idea of a church
breakfast or a farmer market where
you're not doing the preparation on
site
so the definition of an occasional Food
Service establishment is again provided
for the public on the premise Prem so
that the expectation is that you're
making that food on the pre on the
premises right so how would that fit
into the farmers market where you're
bringing a bunch of prepared things that
you're then assembling on site so that
that again you wouldn't be allowed to do
that You' be you're limited to on-site
preparation you're not supposed to so
you're like are you baking the bread
there how does that work so a bread
would be something if it's baked bread
it would be something you'd be allowed
to do in a home food operation and then
you could bring it to the Farmers Market
okay and then about the statute in terms
of
occasional is there somewhere in the
statute where it says it can't be a
regularly scheduled event because the
way that I read the statute is that it's
4 days in a 30-day period regardless of
whether it's regularly scheduled or
not so it's four days and a i four days
and a 30-day period I'm not quite I'm
not quite sure there again there's a
separate definition for occasional food
service event so for establishment so it
can be regular if it's an EST occasional
Food Service establishment it just has
to not go above the threshold of four
days in a 30day period exactly
okay okay thank you for those
explanations and
continue and then finally we have what's
called a temporary Food Service
establishment so this is any food
service establishment which operates at
a fixed location for a period of time
not to exceed two weeks in conjunction
with a Fair carnival circus public
exhibition or simil similar transitory
Gathering and so this would be certainly
um probably something that's freshed in
our minds would be hopkington fair like
th those all those Food Service vendors
at the hopkington fair have no oversight
no licensing requirements from from our
um from our section Deerfield fair is
another example um it doesn't mean if
you which I'll get to in the next slide
is there are self- inspecting cities and
towns and so some of them do license
temporary events so Manchester for
example conquered those are there are 15
self- inspecting cities and towns which
are on this map that may have different
regulations so in Manchester I know they
do license even like church dinners or
church breakfast they have what it's a
reduced license but they do have a
licensing process for that so um that's
what I just want to M make that that can
U make that point that it also can
create confusion because there are
differences and regulations depending on
the jurisdiction and who has the
regulatory oversight when it comes to
food do you know what statute gives them
the authority to be a self-inspect city
or town so in it's in RSA
47 and I can get you the exact uh
um the EXA the exact location within
that statute okay sure thank
you uh
represent thank you madam chairman Miss
Smith
um what were we talking about about the
self- inspecting T yes so if this
legislation was to move forward in
whatever form it takes um it would be
reasonable to uh accept the 15
self-regulating cities which would
answer the concerns like of the
Manchester uh Health Department for
example so I I do know that I I do know
that the cities and towns feel very
strongly about being able to make their
own they you know certainly collect um
revenues from licensing those events
they um feel very strongly some of them
have zoning requirements that don't
allow home food production so they feel
very strongly about keeping those um
those their status for being able to
permit the events that they do
intact follow up M Madam chair yeah go
ahead follow yes um and I will admit
that that didn't come to mind when I was
doing the self- inspecting cities didn't
come to mind so it was my
mistake
okay any other questions so far no go
ahead
so and I just these are our contact
information so if you have any follow-up
questions after uh after today's meeting
we'd be happy to take them um and and
we're here to provide information on the
current regulation we would definitely
we understand that there's a lot of
confusion this these weren't these
weren't um regulations that we Creed in
of our own we have to interpret them and
try to do our best with what we know is
was the intent at the time um we feel
very strongly that uh supporting local
food an opportunity but we also have to
be cognizant of food safety risk and we
know that home kitchens while people may
be well-intentioned is that they're not
always designed to do um Mass amounts of
food production they don't have the they
don't have facilities that were designed
to cool foods for instance um in in a
quick man so if you're making large
amounts of of chili or soup um that's
certainly a consideration we also want
to point out is is that we have
exemptions for licensing which do make
does make it very very difficult to
enforce and we do get complaints uh we
get complaints about homesteads people
not doing what they're what they're
allowed to do making things like
cheesecakes or or other foods that
require refrigeration our respons is is
that we try to reach out with bya letter
to those folks um first and explain to
them that this is the regulation you're
not allowed to do these Foods in your
home you can do these Foods or you can
pursue Licensing in a commercial kitchen
but I I do want to say that it can be
very difficult for us to enforce this we
don't regularly enforce farmers markets
where a lot of Home H produced foods are
being offered um we did actually have a
summer intern who worked with us and did
some surveying at Farmers Market Market
um and did some assessments and we'd be
happy to share her findings um you know
she found labeling was probably the
biggest thing that she found out of
compliance at when she did that survey
at the farmers markets so we do know as
best as we can to try to inform people
of what the regulations are is that
there are things that are are happening
um that that we that we might not know
about or um have a very difficult time
enforcing okay I I have a question and
so as far as um Foods allowed to be made
in Homestead food operations you had a
whole
list excuse me um where does dried foods
and freezed dried foods fall in that
list so if it's an air dried food like
air like a dried herb or spice we have
we've allowed that in a homestead when
it comes to freeze drying that that's
considered a process and we know there
could be food safety risks with not
getting that U the correct water
activity in a freeze dried in a freeze
dried situation so that's not a product
that we've allowed in a homestead
operation
okay um I'm sorry okay hold on one
second I'm sorry yeah put you uh
representative costable could you yes
thank you madam sure sure thank you for
taking my question um you said you sent
out you send letters out as your first
Contact for some somebody that is not
following the rules or statutes can you
give us um the number of letters that
you've sent out either yearly or over a
period of time sure I I can go I would
have to go back and get that exact
number I'd say it's probably on the
order of 20 maybe a
year okay representative um go on it's
been a long thank you mad summer for
getting everybody that's okay um thank
you for putting together the
presentation I like the information um
just wondering if you DHHS if you guys
have thought a little bit more if you
have any more opinions about labeling
requirements because uh this these types
of uh legislation you know the 14 other
states or whoever many now have had
success with having having uniform
labeling requirements and so we are kind
of seeing here that we have a problem
with uh duplicity or
duplicative things because New Hampshire
is uh you know well known for being a
local control you know state so we do
have these kind of confusing guidelines
uh coming from the state level and then
we can you know a locality can just say
we don't want any of this so you know
have you guys thought a little bit about
maybe just having uniform labeling
requirements and would that help because
it seems to me that that could help you
know with farmers markets and uh like a
community
event so so just so I I can understand
so are you talking
about like like ingredient labeling are
you talking about the the exempt from
yeah so one idea that been kicked around
a little bit is to have
DHHS in charge of enforcing labeling so
you like the state could even design a
label and the state could just have a
label that would have you know the the
person could customize it and basically
everyone would be required to use this
label for these types of
products so so we do have have a sample
label on our website that lists the the
minimum information that has to be on
that label I think some of the problems
with standardizing the the label is is
the you know the size of the them
because certainly you might have a candy
manufacturer that is very different than
someone making jams and jellies and and
can do different things with their label
so we definitely do have um standardized
information that's required to be on
that label but as far as any kind of
format that that's not something that
we're prescriptive on on the layout of
that information is that something um
the apartment is receptive toward I
think it would probably be more um we
would definitely want to take Industries
impact into that because they you know
certainly they're bearing the burden of
of having that information on their
product we definitely just want to make
sure the content and information is is
there in a format that's readable and
understandable to to a
consumer okay and then um Miss leader
zos right yeah go ahead Addie I wanted
to say that I think that the
Department's labeling requirements are
very clear you just Google like
Homestead Foods New Hampshire and
there's a thing that tells you yeah it
has to be in 10-point font and it has to
have these elements and there's a sample
label um the idea of having a template
for the label I think would be very
harmful to producers like us um we spend
a lot of time making sure that our
labels match our aesthetic that they are
clear to Consumers that they're
appealing that they highlight the
information that we want to highlight
like you know special ingredients that
might be in there what's from our farm
what's made in New Hampshire and
requiring us to match the design of
everybody else's labels is such a huge
kick in the teeth to your marketability
that I think it would be just a terrible
idea sorry that's okay I'm glad you
showed
up you don't you don't want a whole
shelf of JS that all have the exact same
label particularly when you have to use
the same recipes unless you're willing
to pay for a process
review um I'm sorry I forgot your name
my name is Linda Paulson thank you madam
chair sure um I am in agreeance that I
believe a standardized label is going to
be very difficult to enforce for the
simple fact that different products
carry different ingredient lists and yes
a candy maker May potentially have many
more ingredients than someone simply
producing a chocolate chip cookie uh in
terms of
labeling a thought uh if DHHS were to
offer an online class that offered a
certificate at the end of one hour or
whatever time frame were required to
teach these are the elements that that
we have on our website and then you have
oversight of who is knowledgeable of
that proper labeling might that be a
solution that could satisfy that
standardized
requirement and the freedom
to allow your product to stand out with
whether it's your farm product or your
specialized ingredient
so yeah I'm interested to know know um
what your thoughts are of providing some
sort of online course or doing some kind
of course through UNH
extension uh to provide some of our
producers with more information so that
it's not you know somebody produces
something and say oh my God how do I
sell this and rather than them going out
and just doing
whatever um you know this would I think
go a long way to helping people
understand what they need to do and how
they need to do it you know we you know
always are in support of of educational
opportunities and and food safety
increasing food in safety for our
producers and being able to have those
forms to answer questions because we we
certain we know that it can be confusing
we we spend a lot of hours on the phone
each and every day trying to answer
questions of what folks can and cannot
do and and how to do things properly or
guide iding them to um whether it's uh
extension resources from New Hampshire
or eain to to get further food safety
information so we definitely would be in
support of that um the way I just want
to also just emphasize is that the way
way our current structure is with having
that exempt group of exempt group from
licensing we could make it a a a
suggested or voluntary program but
without having there's no registration
or no process for us to document that
any that someone has taken that class if
they're an exempt home well that's what
I would think is that if they were going
to take this online course that that
would somehow register them with your
department and that at the completion of
that course they can receive some sort
of certification to show that they've
been through that
training and and been through it
successfully maybe they have to have you
know pass some sort of test or something
at the end um uh you know then perhaps
maybe that would allow them
um to produce foods that are not made in
Homestead food operations if they had
you know the
training um in in how to produce fresher
frozen soups or cheesecakes or whatever
in a safe manner so I don't know what
your thought is on that I'd like to know
so so certainly I I think training is a
step in the right direction I do just
want to Circle back to we have there's
the concern is also the equipment
limitations in a home home kitchen
setting is that you have you might have
a you have your household food that you
have stored in your refrigerator but now
if you're you are have this growing
business that you also now have to
figure out how am I going to put this
kettle of soup in or a she pan of soup
in to make sure it cools Pro properly is
that is that we we also want to be
cognizant of the limitations that there
can be in a home environment for being
able to to do the other parts of this
not only not only labeling but um but
keeping food at the required
temperatures so is a
concern the amount of food that a person
is producing on some scheduled amount
you know weekly or daily or whatever um
in so far as what they'd be able to sell
so it would be the amount and and again
um the the type of food is that that the
way the homestead food operation now it
it's very it's limited to things that
have controls when you have a Bak good a
cookie is you're cooking you're baking
that you're cooking it it's shelf stable
when you have something like a
cheesecake you're also baking it but now
you have to store it at in a
refrigerator if you have 20 cheesecakes
if you have two cheesecakes maybe there
maybe there's a difference in how you
can do that safely but how how do we
make a regulation that says you can only
make two cheesecakes you can't make 20
because we don't trust your home
refrigerator that that's where you know
it becomes very very difficult to parse
when you have when you make that
allowance for um things that require
temperature control to to um to figure a
uh the best pathway forward when when
ultimately you have to consider we're
we're allowing this in a in a home
kitchen okay representative K you had a
question I did I just wanted to go back
to the labeling thing and I think that
um instead of the department taking it
on um to work in conjunction with the
UNH extension uh Cooperative because
they offer a lot of classes and they do
a lot uh in conjunction with dhh they've
had a very successful rabbit and poultry
course um that has been rolled out and
has been offered for years now um and
people have come to know and if through
the Farm Bureau and advertising with DH
HS if UNH periodically would offer that
extension would offer that course
online um you know and then people could
print out a certificate once they
completed it I think that would be a
plus um you know if we wanted to have
some sort of training I mean obviously
it shouldn't need to be required um
because it's not required now and I'm
looking at they they do have a sample of
what a label looks like right on uh the
homestead uh page uh for chocolate chip
cookies if anyone wants to uh know
what's in chocolate chip cookies um but
that would be my suggestion is to be
working with UNH extension Cooperative
because uh they really do specialize in
educational uh programs representative
kraton had a question I'll go
around yes ma'am um thank you again for
your your testimony it's as always your
spot on um
I'm looking at I'm looking at the at the
uh at the bill and and the way I read
this is that you want the the
recommendation is to create Artisan
foods that allow the sale of those
things that are now restricted to
sell is that so that would be my
understanding of the bill and and I I
would also defer to representative alaer
as I know she
she she had put it forward so she might
have more insight into um into the uh
the the completeness of what you were
looking to do okay for a followup a
followup yeah okay and I'll I'll wait
for the for that but but as you read
this though and and you've brought up
specifically the
refrigeration issue um this from a DHHS
perspective opens the the gate a little
bit too far in terms of what can
reasonably healthily be sold safely be
sold we definitely have concerns about
opening opening up the the window for um
expansion of things that require
refrigeration for safety and also we
also want to think about the ven as as I
recall in the in the in the bill as
proposed is that it it allowed these to
be offered at many many locations it
wasn't just um you know n I'm coming to
your house or your Farmstand and I want
to buy this product it that they could
be sold in in stores they could be sold
at restaurants is that we definitely
have a concern if is making sure people
are aware that these are made in a home
food operation um and
that the the also the locations that
they're made um certainly we we wouldn't
want somebody um who has a restaurant to
go be making all their prepping at home
and then bringing this to the restaurant
the customer has thinks they're
purchasing food that was made at the
restaurant and it was actually made you
know in in somebody's home kitchen is is
also full disclosure to the consumer to
make those choices as well okay great
thank you um Miss leader
elos labeling um I think a lot of you
are talking in generalities oh there's
problems with labels people don't know
how to do them it might be helpful to
dial in a little bit more on what
aspects of the labels people AR missing
and I will say that from having
participated in tons of online baking
forums for people who bake at home
there's really three issues with the
labeling one is that um people don't
understand how
to write out the sub ingredients of
things like baking powder or a
commercial item like a Oreo that they're
putting into their homebaked thing two
is that a lot of Home Bakers don't know
how to convert from a volume measurement
to a weight measurement so they have a
hard time putting those items in order
and they might not do it correctly and
then their label is wrong and three is
the requirement to have your address
your home address on a product that
you're selling at the farmers market I
think there are a lot of concerns um
particularly among the demographic that
most commonly is doing home baking which
is women about personal safety you hear
this question all the time how how
should I sell my stuff at the farmers
market so that people don't know exactly
where me and my kids live I'm a single
mom whatever there was a very very
widely publicized um home invasion and
rape of a home Baker in Iowa where
someone came to her home pretending to
be a customer only knew about it from
the label on her product um and then
obviously had this horrible violent
event happen to her and so I wonder
Colleen if you're seeing these three
problems addresses weights and ordering
things um and some ingredients if those
are some of the most common problems or
if there are other problems that you're
seeing with the labels so I I think that
I think you did hit those spot on is
that th those are problems we have we
have allowed people to put a an email
address in L of a physical address if
they if as we just want to have be able
to let the consumer have a way to
contact that person if they have any
questions or concerns about the product
you consider something like a producer
number which is what like Maryland
Arkansas Minnesota they offer the option
of either having your home address or a
health department assigned producer
number so that your address is blocked
from sort of public
knowledge I think it as long as there
was an established means of of some way
that that consumer would be able to be
able to get more information about the
product or if you know they they
experienced an adverse event you know
chipped a tooth or or they might just
want to order more or more order more
hey you
know uh representative award
thank you madam
chairman Miss Smith um back to
labeling the Crux of my bill was to open
up the industry the homemade food
industry to include potentially
hazardous foods
or TS TCS
Foods um and in that was the very most
important labeling requirement of the
statement refrigerat right after
purchase not after opening but after
purchase which designates it as a you
know it could even say
perishable refrigerate after purchase so
the onus is on the consumer if buying uh
fresh salsa that's vended out of a
cooler filled with ice for
example um have you thought about that
particular
statement in relation to whether or not
this bill moves forward to allow TCS
Foods so so I think having a clear con
having clear instructions for the
consumer about how the food should be
stored that that that should be that
that would be an important an important
um aspect of this however I think it's
it's more the downstream is where is
where we are have our concerns about how
is it is it held under proper
temperature at production through
distribution um to that consumer right
followup Madam chair yeah follow up um
yes that would be included in what I'm
proposing as a type of food safety
course that would be a requirement it
would be in the law and administrative
rules um
so given the fact that we don't have
that many complaints and that this has
been rampant non-compliance for decades
plus Community dinners that are serving
thousands of people across the state uh
with foods that are advertised as you
know
homemade um this is where I'm trying to
get to with DHHS And in regards to the
statement that you sent me by email that
domestic Refrigeration was not adequate
for food production
that's what you wrote um if you have a
domestic refrigerator that holds at 41
degrees or less and you have a
commercial unit that holds it 41 degrees
or
less and if you
have uh homemade food producers making
small
batches typically they are small batches
of whatever they make because they're
not going to
take 75 bottles of salsa to a farmer
Market if they can only s sell
10 so it seems to me that DHHS is
imposing this kind of dire um extreme on
the homemade food producers who have no
intention of exceeding their
Refrigeration capacity you know they
could bring in coolers for that matter
overnight and then go vend the next day
for example so so I I just wanted to
make that comment thank you okay I'm
going to go to representative costable
and then over this side again go ahead
thank you madam chair um and just to
bounce off of of that uh we do me me and
my wife do sell at farmers markets and
we sell uh fruit pies and one of the
things we would love to be able to do is
um um sell periodically we have uh
Thanksgiving coming up we would like to
be able to sell
uh pumpkin pie right and it it seems
like that um it just is honorous I we've
we've done I've I've asked everybody it
is universal when we say people ask us
can you do it nope sorry we can't do it
why not so um the the limitation on the
food is pretty much to what our extra we
have an extra refrigerator what can we
fit in there it would be probably eight
pies if we and we would pre-order order
them so people would know they're coming
specifically for those pie and that's
that's that's the extent we're just
trying to get a little bit more I'm
we're not we're never going to be a
commercial kitchen we're never going to
we're never going to sell 50 potentially
hazardous foods in a day it's very
limited to what we can do which is small
batches really small batches and they're
from people that we know we know these
people so one of the ideas that we were
tossing around on the labeling side was
so we have fruit pies and that has the
exempt from um that has the exemption
label on it along with all the other
stuff we had talked about um I would I
would say I'm not opposed to a warning
label on TCS food so next to your fruit
pies that has the exemption that were
were exempt from inspection would be if
we're selling anything that has
temperature control would be a warning
label to Consumers that way they they
fully understand that this product for
one it's a it's a conversation starter
because the law would be changing it
would be something new that we're there
that we're able to sell and so it would
be a conversation started for one to
educate them that this is different and
it needs refrigeration and it's just
that that gives the consumer um the
information they need that this is um
needs to be refrigerated and uh it
separates it from the the other um
exemption label so it could be a
different label is what we're saying and
and again just just to say it's because
we're not I'm we're not looking for to
do this great big amount it's just a
little bit here a little bit extra here
a little bit here and usually
seasonality plays into a huge part of
that and it's not um you know the to me
the potential risk is extremely low when
we just participated in in food sales
and fundraisers and everything we didn't
we don't produce it ourselves but
everyone else had potentially hazardous
food nobody's gotten sick right it's
it's uh like like they were saying
thousands this this occurs all over the
state without a problem it just seems to
be a problem when we want to exchange it
for
money anyway thank you I I don't know
your name yeah no that's okay so yes so
I just want to introduce myself I'm
Wendy Johnny I'm the food safety State
special for un Cooperative Extension
nice to meet you and likewise Madam
chair and others um so I just in terms
of I did wanted to offer myself in terms
of uh any sort of uh feedback input um
in relation to the sort of food safety
piece of things but also wanted to um
you mentioned UNH Cooperative Extension
working closely on some of this work and
I just want to emphasize that we have
and we've enjoyed that week work we
thought it has been very important I
know for the rabbit and poultry course
and then also just in this Homestead
food operation space too we have done
educational Mater we have education
materials and we actually have gone out
to different sites and done sometimes in
collaboration sometimes on our own some
work in relation to education around
this and we would be welcome to
potentially future sort of educational
material in this noting that if you are
going to bring in UNH extension probably
worth discussing terms of just our
capacity too I actually wear two hats we
have two other team members um
uh but definitely of interest and what
so what's your uh feasibility for
offering an online course for uh
potential food producers yeah so I think
it really depends on what the the an
online course can take a variety of
different it can play out in a variety
of different ways I mean we do the
rabbit and poultry course which actually
is online but moving to in person um so
I think if an online C could be
something that is just a one andone kind
of you actually have a recording with an
online course so it could be something
of that nature so I think it really
depends on what it is we we are I'd say
booked Beyond capacity right now I'm not
going to pretend we are not so I do
think if it's something that is we
should have additional discussions
potentially depending on what you're
thinking and what that could potentially
look like and I know that DHHS also does
a lot of work in that space as well yeah
um representative kto and then I'll come
back over here thank you madam chair I
just wanted to follow up on something
you said uh we have had um people from
UNH extension into our town uh for food
safety and uh they do great
presentations um so they do come out to
uh if if you request that in your town
or maybe a group um they're very
receptive okay over here thank you madam
chairwoman um my name is Michael
Williams I'm Addie's husband and her
business partner um and I wanted to just
kind of put some things out into the
space here uh in terms of this
discussion uh based on our experience
combined 25 years running um
professional food operations and um both
have been served safe and food handler
certified in states that have way more
regulation and education requirements
than New Hampshire um which is partially
one of the reasons we live in New
Hampshire now um but um a couple of
things in terms of um your concern about
Commercial Refrigeration is absolutely
valid um one of the things one of the
most important pieces of safety
equipment in a kitchen is the
refrigeration and there's already a
requirement that was communicated to us
through our inspecting agent that any um
Refrigeration temperature equipment must
be commercial freezers don't necessarily
have to be for the farm store and that
made perf sense to me and the the thing
that she's describing where you have
like a huge pot of soup or a big hotel
pan a home refrigerator does not have
the capacity through the cooling coils
to move that heat around fast enough to
cool that down at a safe time period or
to guarantee that it will it's not just
about keeping the temperature low it's
about getting the temperature yeah it's
about how fast the temperature changes
so um you know it seems obvious to me
that one of the things that we can do if
someone does want to make Artisan food
and use TC and produce and sell TCS
Foods out of a home kitchen it's not it
if we wanted to put in a two-door Tron
refrigerator that was used we'd spend
$1,500 go pick it up spend about 500
bucks to have a technician look at it to
make sure that it's working up to spec
and then we've spent $2,000 on a
refrigerator that helps us make safe
food if we are required to build a
commercial kitchen in our particular
instance we're probably looking at over
$100,000 we have to install a new septic
system we have to install a new power
supply and a new box like there's like
it's uh the difference between replacing
a piece of equipment or adding a piece
of equipment to a home environment which
can run on home power just fine you
might have to have an electrician run a
220 line or something but uh and and
spending uh you know six figures
possibly building a commercial kitchen
whereas the the thing that makes that
food safe when it's changing
temperatures is not the air gapped
Plumbing it's not the handwashing
stations it's the refrigerator um the
you know also something that we've
noticed something that made itself very
obvious to us since we opened our farm
store last November um there are people
who come to our farm store who are
looking for whole raw ingredients that
are extremely high quality and carefully
grown and all this but for the most part
people are looking for prepared foods so
in terms of the economic viability of a
small business you have to be able to
sell things that people want to buy and
there's a limit to how many muffins and
how many brownies yeah
yeah compared to sayt pot pies if we
could put pot pies and hummus in our
fridge we would have absolutely no
Financial concerns you know we know that
we would be absolutely mobbed okay so um
that's a serious concern um and in terms
of food safety you know both with the
labeling and with food safety no one's
going to have a higher incentive to make
sure the food they sell is safe than the
person selling it their livelihood
depends on that and one one bad
complaint one association with food born
illness from DHHS destroys your business
instantaneously it takes a decade to
overcome that stuff I've seen it happen
even with established restaurants that
were doing millions of dollars a year in
sales they have become unviable in the
space of three months because of things
like this um so it's really important to
the person who's running the business
and whose livelihood depends on it to
make sure that their food is safe and go
going back to the labeling requirements
you can set up a class to make sure
people uh understand the labeling
requirements and all that I think you
guys have done a great job of making it
clear what's required on the label it's
very easy to find it's very easy to
understand and um you know I go back to
my experience in the military and the
three most dreaded letters in the
military are CBT computer-based training
if you have to go on and sit there and
click through a training uh uh
slideshow that is something people
really genuinely don't want to do and
what ends up happening is you click
through you barely pass the test at the
end and you get your certificate whereas
you've got basically two people doing
business people who want to scale People
Like Us who want to do this full-time
and want to make it our entire living
who in New Hampshire with given the
population and population density it is
impossible for us to fly under the radar
we are small we don't even having a
thousand followers on Facebook yet but
we've already been referred to in our
town as celebrities Okay so like there
is no possibility that a food operation
our size or the size we want to be is
going to fly under the radar
here people who want to do it as a side
business who are not relying on it for
their primary
income whether you put the training up
there or not they are much more likely
to try and operate in the gray or stay
out of sight and they're not going to
care about the laboring requirements
either way whether you do an online
course or not so um for us we want to
make sure the label is on there for us
like we were going to label it anyway
because there are allergens there are
things that people um are are preferring
to avoid in their diet that are going to
be in our foods that we want to make
sure they have the opportunity to see in
our Foods um and you know one of the
things about the The Artisan food
legislation that's been proposed is it
opens the door in some people's opinions
too wide but also it opens the door to
the professionalization of local food in
this state um the more you allow people
to make a living fully on this the more
professionals will be drawn to doing it
and the more safe the food will become
and as you mentioned there's like three
complaints you send out 20 letters in a
year it sounds like the food's pretty
safe based on incentives and if you want
to have oversight I can understand that
but the the more you allow this space to
be professionalized the more likely you
are to get safe
food so I just want to add a couple of
things too is
that especially
postco people are more drawn to uh
trying to obtain locally grown food when
we're seeing uh reports all the time of
you know all these recalls from Bor head
uh deli food
and uh you know Tyson chicken recalls
and all other kind of these Mega big
producers having problems because of the
amount of food that they're producing
and not being able to keep it
temperature controlled or germ free or
whatever
so more is the impetus
for people wanting to have something
from their local Farm or something a
small smaller operation where where
things really are um paid attention to
and I think that's where a lot of this
feeling is coming from this kind of
legislation we saw more than one bill
hit my committee this year having to do
with expansion of what uh our farmer our
farmers and small local producers can
offer because people want it and um and
and I just think that that this is this
is something that we really seriously
have to take a look at to see where in
our statutes we can make some uh more
accommodation but I also understand the
issue of risk management um the more
food is being produced the more there is
a possibility perhaps of uh foodborn
Illness but from what we're seeing in um
um where more producers are starting to
enter the market um we're not seeing in
a huge uptick in in foodborn illness or
letters being written to DHHS saying
somebody was poisoned um so I I think
that we really we really have to find a
way um to make some of this expansion
happen because the consumers want it
they want locally grown stuff um and
locally produced stuff because they feel
that they can trust that more than what
they're starting to see in their own
supermarkets um with that I don't know
if there's any other questions or
comments
for DHHS and their presentation but I'd
certainly like to have representative
aart talk about her bill a little bit
more
and so if there are any other questions
you had
question about um the bill in terms of
I'm a little confused about why we're
talking about creating a new um food
safety course or program um there's
already a lot of there's a national
program called Serve Safe that's used
everywhere and almost everyone who works
in a restaurant at some point gets it
it's you know you can take a weekend
class you can do it online you can um do
it once a week you can there there's all
these options it's very well program
it's not that expensive for people to
take we had talked about that in our
committee uh with one of the other bills
and what we had discovered was that with
serve
save it sort of um was a little bit
above and beyond what a local producer
would need and also had a big component
having to do with handling
shellfish and and items like that and um
it I think you do have different courses
is what was your opinion on that so so
SP so Sur safe is is designed for
certified food protection manager so
those are it's it's really geared to
people that are running a a restaurant
or a deli or or a a a reg a grocery I'm
sorry a restaurant food service so it it
it is more it's not necessarily geared
to someone that's preparing jellies and
jams while there might be some
principles that are applicable it's it's
really not about package food produ
production in its emphasis it's about
you know employee health and hygiene and
monitoring health and hygiene cooling
there there are yeah parts that come
into play but it's really not designed
for a home food producer or someone
that's making predominantly packaged
foods and I I really appreciate the
folks that have come to speak today
because one thing that's I mean these
these aren't our regulations we we have
to act to what the current law has and
but and I want to recognize is that
we've we've made changes to this law
over time we've it used to be income
limit based there used to be a $5,000
Homestead like if you made $5,000 or
less you were a tier one if you made
$10,000 or more you were tier two we
took away the income limits we we up the
income limits and then took the income
limits away we changed that now you can
sell products to retail stores and we've
done a little bit of changes over time
but kind of what I'm hearing is is this
still this still isn't maybe it wasn't
maybe what we were doing was trying to
incrementally change things but it
really wasn't what was going to help
small producers ultimately and I think
what the the challenge for this
committee is is trying to figure out how
how can we frame something up to open
some doors but also have limitations to
make sure that things can there that the
sky is not the limit that that we're not
um becoming a fulls scale Bakery in in a
home kitchen um because that can lead to
other problems it could lead to food
born illness it could lead to failed
septic systems is that that there are
there's like a spiraling thing to of
consideration but maybe there's
opportunities for someone to make 10
pumpkin pies in a season like I but but
that's kind of the challenge before you
all is that to come up with something
that might makes sense but also
recognizing by opening that what also
can fall into that are we allowing home
Caterers are we allowing people to make
prepared prepared meals are we allowed
to make cheese in our bathtubs like we
we have to think about by giving an
inches that it might not just mean you
can make 10 pumpkin pies it can open the
window for for more things so that's
just just my um my as I I feel that
hearing from this that there's something
broken here I don't have the answers but
I can just present as to what the
current regulation is and and we really
appreciate that too this is kind the
conversations that have to be had to
kind of tease out and figure out where
we want to go what we want to what we
want to see happen and and whether or
not you know those ideas are detrimental
or not uh representative
K thank you thank you madam chair um
sitting here listening
and um knowing that we're looking at a
home kitchen versus commercial kitchen
but somewhere there's something in
between um and that's where the
disconnect is um because people don't
want to go full-blown commercial but yet
they want to make some foods that may be
temperature controlled but yet under the
homestead food act if you add commercial
equipment then you kind of moved away
from the homestead into the
commercial where if we're talking about
temperature controlled maybe we could
allow them to get a you know a specific
type of refrigerator or a freezer so
that they can that can be certified or
inspected so they can sell some
temperature controlled foods and maybe
we make it seasonal or specific to
holidays um to start with um um so I'm
just throwing out some ideas and um but
I don't know but going from you know a
homestead to a commercial is a lot of
money and it's very expensive and it's
not doable for for most people
so
okay thank you m chairman thank you oh
sorry go ahead thank you thank you uh in
response to want to acquest to the
safety of our communities and allow
pumpkin pies chocolate dipped
strawberries
hummus um I have brainstormed with some
other local Bakers in my community
something that we are not sure whether
it exists currently or not and I'm
calling it the uh 24 rule 24 in a 30-day
period 4 days where within a 24-hour
period pies could be made on site s sold
on site received on site it protects the
refrigeration it protects the consumer
in that direct conversation of I'm
taking this from my refrigerator you
must keep it refrigerated for your
safety it could be an option in a
direction to go to appease all parties I
don't know the degree and volume of what
you're doing but for eight pies in the
month of November the 24 rule of you get
4 days within that 30-day period 24
hours to produce those pies have your
consumers that pre-order pick up and
they must be out of your kitchen
otherwise they are no longer sailable
could be an option to visit in terms of
protecting our communities and still
allowing our homesteaders Artisan Bakers
whatever we call them
the freedom to do their trade and bring
more product to within the state on the
I I don't recall the exact wording but
it was
uh elevated stance of a product and I
believe in New Hampshire we have the
ability to do that and we have the
ability right now to visit this
conversation on how Elevate that for our
Homestead Artisan producers so thank you
okay uh Addy yeah I just wanted to say
um I think that is the
most the pivotal Point within New
Hampshire law that can be changed most
easily and most safely is the idea of
changing the occasional Food Service
establishment to an occasional food
establishment so that it includes the
sale of um items that are intended for
off- premise consumption instead of just
items for on premise consumption um and
it would be a very easy change it
doesn't change anything about the
regulations of how the food is prepared
um it's already pretty much been proven
safe as we talked about that people can
make time temperature controlled for
food for safety Foods in their home
kitchens um safely so it doesn't change
that at all but it would allow producers
like us a lot more freedom um to
occasionally provide those typ products
for sale um and I kind of like wrote it
up a little bit if anyone wants to look
at yeah I I have your uh testimony I
wrote more because I get a little
involved um so it's a little bit more
extensive okay I'd like to um spend just
maybe 15 minutes um with representative
award to explain some of the highlights
of the legislation that she the
intentions that she had with that and
again you know this this bill as it
is um is not going to become law uh it
it right now I mean it's uh we're we're
studying this we're we're trying to
maybe maybe take pieces of what um what
we have and trying to incorporate that
into uh current current statute so um
but I just I wanted to get every
everybody to have a sense of of um the
intention of what this legislation was
so go ahead representative Alward
and thank you Madame
chairman
um I used to have a licensed home
kitchen back when it was required and I
made Gourmet brownies and I took them to
events and vended them so I was very
familiar with the laws I'm a former
wholesale and Retail Bakery um owner
Family
Bakery and I work for Safeway stores as
a head cake decorator for many years so
I take a keen interest in um baked goods
especially homemade baked goods uh that
I encounter in my
travels what I found as a vendor myself
was that there were people selling uh
temperature controlled
Foods uh which baffled me because it
wasn't allowed I learned that there
wasn't resources for inspections etc
etc um and just went on my Merry way and
most recently I helped a woman get into
the homemade food business which brought
me back to all these events and looking
at the homemade food vendors and the
labeling and being rather appalled by
the non-compliance it was absolutely
rampant uh when anything from caramel
that was Jarred in a can um made with
milk or cream um to fasha cheese uh you
just name it so I turned around and made
a public record request and this is well
before I was a legislator I had no idea
I would become elected to this position
at the time uh it was just out of
curiosity and being a formerly regulated
individual as a private investigator and
detective agency owner so once you're
kind of licensed you you like to play
the by the rules um so I asked DHHS for
evidence of food born illness originally
I got back answers that said there were
no complaints you know along the way the
house researcher came up with the three
uh in five
years
so I then discovered the double standard
whereby nonprofits municipalities and
private
Enterprise can set up an event
and not be regulated but by the homemade
foods that are brought to the donated to
these events so just over the past two
weekends I went to two separate events
one um featured C egg custard pie at
room temperature sitting out on the
tables
um it also had cream pies which are not
allowed for a homemade uh homemade food
producer to make and so I took the
custard pie I ate it I didn't get sick I
then went to another event where they
had pulled pork that was at tepid
temperature along with
klaw and I ate it and I didn't get
sick so um my biggest question here was
how can we have a double standard where
these nonprofits can take homemade foods
and sell them and serve them to
Consumers to attendees and we still have
these numbers of 20 letters and three
you know complaints over five years um
and I totally agree
with there's a liability involved if you
um don't make good food or save food Etc
but to this date I see zucchini bread
banana bread zucchini bread banana bread
sold
everywhere and quite frankly I leave my
banana bread on the counter for up to 3
days I don't like to refrigerate it um
nobody's gotten sick so
the no one came up to me and said we
want to make these um uh temperature
controlled Foods nobody I was just
uh going through the internet and found
the Institute of justice and they rated
New Hampshire as a c minus for food
Freedom as in comparison to the other
laws uh states that have deregulated the
industry um so I called them up and I
said hey what would it take to make New
Hampshire an
A+ and now I'm a legislator and I can
kind of do something about this so so
they help me formulate the language that
you see in this bill it's first time for
me I you know blindly trusted I I
fine-tuned it uh to what I was seeing in
the marketplace the reality of the
marketplace and put it in a
bill so this was my you know first bill
submission it got all caught up with
farmers markets and uh that had to
itl because I'd gotten bum
information
and what this problem is solving is to
make it fair and
reasonable for the homemade food
producer to produce Foods the same as
these nonprofits are allowed in my mind
you either regulate the
nonprofits just like us to make it fair
and reasonable
or you leave them alone and you let the
homemade food producers make more
different
foods I don't see how you can reconcile
the
two as it is right
now so besides bringing uh New Hampshire
into line with the other states that
have different you know deregulation of
these Foods um um I suggested the
disclaimer on the label in in the name
of Public Safety for the TS or
perishable foods I like the idea of
warning warning perishable refrigerate
after purchase I like that so my
question for UNH I didn't catch your
name I'm so
sorry thank you y Wendy
um what if a panel of a student
you know industry folk were to get
together and formulate a type of
test that you know being boots on the
ground they they could have a better
feel for what might be offered
online is that kind of
possible so in terms of you're speaking
about educational materials that might
be built in with into the scope of the
legislation
yes I think that's what you're speaking
to correct yeah um I think anytime you
are going to develop any educational
materials if you want them to be
effective you want folks to be weighing
in on what those educational materials
look like I mention the online piece I
appreciate the painfulness you speak to
and whether it's effective or not I
think it really speaks to so yes I think
that if there are educational materials
and bringing in a variety of folks I
don't know if you can hear me to weigh
in on what the best content is or makes
complete sense I and I hope that anyone
who's involved in education would agree
with that okay okay so in the
interim of introducing this bill and
going out in the marketplace and
literally telling people that I'm
working on loosening up the laws um but
at the same time seeing
non-compliance um
there's been interest in dere but when I
say that they're thinking oh we no
longer have to label or I'm not labeling
now and I never will have to okay they
have this demented sort of uh concept of
what deregulation means and so
compliance
um I understand currently compliance is
dependent primarily upon members of the
public
reporting suspicions of
non-compliance and on the other hand
compliance to a homemade food producer
May
mean um I I don't have to do this
because they're not inspecting us
because that's what I've heard out in
the market
place uh elevating the the image of the
industry putting out
PSAs twice annually as I suggest in my
bill
um will increase peer pressure out in
the marketplace I think uh increase
awareness the public might say hey
you're not labeled properly I'm not
going to buy your
product um I think the small batch idea
for many of us or you I consider myself
a home made food producer and I'm not
but I feel like I should be um
anyway we we lost our refrigerator the
night before last it it went dead and we
had to put 15 pints of my companion's
fresh salsa in a cooler with ice but it
had fit reasonably on the middle shelf
of the
refrigerator could he then go and vend
that salsa if it was allowed um safely
by transferring it to a cooler with ice
keeping it submerged and ice and you
know bending it from a location I do not
see why not I do not see how an ice fill
cooler
prohibits the sale of this product or
any product uh that that is in a sealed
container and can take being in ice or
dry ice so I understand the concerns the
department I really really do but at the
same time uh Common Sense has to come
into play here at some point and I
believe the onus is on DHHS to
please prove their
concerns we're just hearing
speculation and I just believe that the
problem that's going to be solved is
it's going to create more business
opportuni ities it's going to put better
food out into the marketplace especially
in rural
areas and you know the woman with the
pot crock pot of baked beans mixed with
meat that was served at the old home day
uh should be able to sell that at a
vending event if she
wants it wasn't plugged
in the the product was
tepid but I ate it
so that's it in a nutshell folks I also
met this um lovely woman Linda Paulson
at a particular Market her products were
100% compliant I could have done you
know a cartwheel at that point because
none of the other vendors were in
compliance and it caused quite a Ruckus
at the at the market that I was looking
at and taking photographs of so I can
prove the DHHS because I'm a lawmaker
and I can no longer turn a blind eye to
this I can't in good conscience Public
Safety I'm going to start reporting the
non-compliance I run into but it upset a
lot of people you know they feel that
they're entitled to not follow the law
somehow I don't understand
so sure um go go ahead and then I I'd
like to hear from um Mr Johnson from
Bureau you've been very quiet over
there I'd like to hear some some some
comments where where your thoughts are
on this but first uh thank you fairw
woman um one of the things as as food
professionals I can say that I as
someone who generally takes a very dim
view of Regulation and Regulatory
Agencies I think DHHS finds himself in a
very um unenviable position of being
they have to attempt simultaneously to
be a regulatory enforcement agency as
well as a consumer advocacy agency as
well as a business advocacy agency and
so they're constantly playing all these
different angles so the position you're
in is difficult
um I when it comes to food safety this
is one of the few areas where I tend to
have uh a very gray and complex sort of
view of Regulation um because I've seen
what people do with food
and I I I have seen non-h handwashing
I've seen people move from
raw products to cooked products without
changing their gloves I mean every idea
that everything you can conceive where
you introduce unsafety to food
processing I have observed it I have
overseen the people doing it corrected
them over and over and over and they
keep doing it I understand how difficult
it is to keep things for the compliance
I also understand that food safety in
terms of the way it's prepared is kind
of like running an Actuarial Table that
you know um there is a threshold where
it's not safe anymore and even beyond
that threshold most people won't get
sick but you reach a certain point where
suddenly a lot of people are sick and it
doesn't take much you don't you can't
really pinpoint where that point is so a
lot of the um uh a lot of the
requirements for food safety are
designed the way bridges are in
engineering where they actually are
rated for a weight and they are their
calculated weight is double that so um
it's it's an overabundance of caution
it's being very careful with food and I
understand that I absolutely advocate
for it um but I think a lot of what we
what you found is that the
non-compliance is I think people there
is a there is a producer education
component that has to go into effect
here which is why I favor an envir which
promotes
professionalization um which makes it
viable for people to make this their
primary income and not a side hustle um
because those are people who are going
to take it more seriously so um in terms
of creating the Artisan food kind of
category I think that's an important
step in the right direction but I also
appreciate the situation you're in
represent yes I'd like to S talk to um
the term side
hustle a lot of these vendor of small
batch food
items are
elderly and they're trying to make an
extra hundred bucks on a weekend to help
pay their taxes or buy their
medications or whatever I have never
seen anybody that even remotely looks
like a professional Homestead food
product uh person except for Miss
Paulson she is
uh beyond belief in her
operation so uh I think we have to look
at um the demographics of who's actually
vending these
products
um I believe you had an intern that was
out in the marketplace is that cor and
we're going to hear from her
and
um I don't see people becoming
professional Homestead that's not the
demographic I'm seeing out in the
marketplace I
I yeah sure but I I'd like to say I
think people from all walks of life all
ages um are are engaging in this because
you know they have a you know Grandma's
favorite recipe or whatever that they
want to share with the public and yeah
make a few extra bucks if they can yeah
um everybody is um you know seems to
want to share something at a farmers's
market or bring to a community dinner or
whatever MH um so yeah I don't I don't
see that it's any one particular
demographic it was all elderly no said
any are Mr Will Williams is it yes thank
you um I I just I want to clarify I
don't have a problem with people doing
that what I'm describing is that the
current regulatory structure um very
effectively precludes
professionalization it makes it very
difficult to make it your primary um to
make this type of business your primary
income so um I would like to open the
door to people to want to do that um
because that's what we want to do
frankly um and um you know I I can
assure you nothing unsafe is ever going
to leave our kitchen we've thrown away
stuff plenty already uh because we
didn't deem it had that be safe so
representative
kulan thank you madam chair yeah so I
think what I'm hearing over here is that
the best thing we can do legislatively
is to try and simplify our statutes
because what I'm hearing and you know I
don't like this idea of you out at
Farmers Market snitching on people that
I I'm a little worried for your health
and safety at that point Beyond food
born illness but
uh police okay good so uh you know if
DHHS wants to open up another you know
Homestead food Sheriff like you might be
good for that but so I think the best
thing that we can do is try with this
group is try and focus on streamlining
and simplifying and I I like where
you're going with opening it up because
we do want it to be you know we want New
Hampshire when when people come here you
know when they're going you know Labor
Day camping or whatever they go to
Walmart they go to Market Basket or
Hanford and they get all their food and
when they come to a small business they
don't want to see the same stuff chopped
up you know they want to see unique
stuff and so this helps our tourism
industry as well if we can have more
artisanal skilled people making very
high quality things that are better than
you can get the supermarket so I see it
as more as like a of a race to the top
than a race to the bottom and the best
thing like with
legislation every change that we make
it's a cause and effect so there's no
like perfect utopian legislation we're
probably never going to wind up at this
perfect Mountaintop of legislation where
everything's perfect and no one has a
complaint cuz you know everything's
going to affect someone in a certain way
so I think the best thing we can do is
try and simplify and streamline and make
it easy for people to understand reading
and then hopefully grow a strong you
know you know vibrant
industry Mr
Johnson would you like to share your
thoughts on behalf of Farm
Bureau well we uh justess
initially um came involved took an
interest from representative Edwood stop
by our office last fall I guess when you
were looking at introducing the bills
and she had some ideas that that uh
brought in farmers markets and initially
we had had concerns with her her wanting
uh to open up a markets for artists and
producers but also drawing in the
farmers market definition and we see
there's a lot of that that definition
those those markets are for farmers are
important to us we there's an Integrity
to that so so and and um but it was
evident from talking with her that she
had done her homework and knew what she
was talking about and a lot of things
made a lot of sense and we certainly um
as far far as the Artisan producers go
so I I think from what you're hearing
there definitely is as repr represent
ktoa mentioned kind of that doughnut
hole where there's that the there's an
area of of of uh food producers that are
are not being uh served like they could
be and need to be um um do you know of
any farms or Farm
stands
that have come to uh New Hampshire Farm
Bureau with suggestions of how they may
or how the law can change so that they
may be able to to um produce and sell
more varied product yeah not recently I
can say years ago prior to I know that
when the homestead food statue was was
uh became law that during that time
period yeah we had a lot of discussions
um more recently no not as not as much
um but I I do think just from from
hearing the potential of some of the
suggestions I can see where it would
would help some um some folks you know
on a small scale to to to you know get
their products into a wider a little bit
wider market and maybe from their
upscale
cuz I mean you know personally I would
love to see uh you know a farmer who is
growing pumpkins be able to sell pumpkin
pies well that yeah and um you know or
if they they've they're beef producers
if they can do uh do up some sort of
casseroles and put them in their freezer
because they already have a farm stand
that has a freezer or refrigerator if
they could uh you know do do those um
kinds of meals uh based on the products
that they're actually raising on their
on their Farm uh I think that that would
be you know something spectacular for
them yeah now most definitely I I can
see we have uh Farmers that sell selling
turkeys you know uh harvested on the
farm under the exemption and adding
pumpkin pies to that you're going to
have those consumers are going to you
know One-Stop shopping type thing be a
benefit I I I do have and I don't know I
don't know if uh um the department has
had a chance to see that the the letter
that you had uh email you had uh
provided me from um from eer Farm
regarding they they have a have you have
they have a uh a a licensed uh Dairy
kitchen and then they aren't able to do
some things and I was curious there why
think you think that could be something
done there as well because they do have
a established license facility um but I
can I can talk with you later about that
yeah the the other question I do have
and that's kind of aside from all this
is I i' listening to some of the
producers here my I have a question
about insurance about how you're dealing
with that and it's aside from the
legislation I know but I can talk to to
you folks off offline here but that's a
question I have is how there how are you
dealing with that
okay so um represent cible oh sorry goad
um just for us to sell at at markets
they required a million doll policy on
General um product liability on it so to
be a part of any of the farmers markets
that we sell at they they required us to
have a commercial um liability I guess
my question is have you discussed with
them the bill this that's what it would
what their response would be there so in
terms of our our insurance actually
wouldn't change because they we went
through an insurance company that is you
know 50 State whatever and all the
answering all the questions none of it
had to do with um uh refrigerated types
of foods or anything like that it was it
was more of um was it uh the um General
types of things but not it didn't get
into that specific of a there are there
are you can go more you know you could
do there was there was opportunities to
have more coverage but the basic million
dooll policy was was sort of
generic okay um sure Colleen I I just
want uh just a couple additional points
is I I know that we have talked about
the complaint number of complaints that
we've received and reports of food born
illness but it it and and I appreciate
that you didn't get sick when you ate
that that pork but but we we have to
sometimes these illnesses are under
reported many times they're under
reported so people can have a stomach
bug get better don't go to the doctor we
don't know about that we don't know
where they we don't know if they made it
at home if they went to a a restaurant
and got sick they went to the um the
church dinner and got sick those some
some things are undetected by us so it
doesn't mean that just because we don't
have reports of them that they're not
happening we have to look at the
possibility of of we know that
microorganisms grow when they're out of
temperature control under certain
conditions and so we have to protect
against that and I I just want to
caution us caution is is that while we
are supportive of growing Local Foods
and the ability for consumers to get
access to Local Foods it it doesn't mean
that they have to be unsafe foods it is
that food in a Haniford versus food at a
farmers's market should be equally safe
and and just because you want to
purchase your food from a local farmer
that doesn't mean that we should
sacrifice on food safety um one thing
that we have we've bounced around this
idea is is potentially having a a like a
voluntary seal of quality or a seal of
of food safety is is having appreciating
that there might be the gamut of people
that are really focused and dedicated
and want to get invest in equipment to
to make more food is having some kind of
whether it's licensing or
registration proof of having it
attending an educational requirement
proof of having um an interface with an
inspector that they haven't he's giving
me a thumbs up th thumbs up is is me and
you know there are similar programs I'm
thinking about apple cider thinking
about honey where these are voluntary
voluntary programs within the Department
of Agriculture but maybe something that
could bridge that Gap is that we're just
not opening the opening the doorway to
more products without some kind of
oversight because what what I'm hearing
is is that this lack of oversight and
I'm not advoc because I also know our
resource limitations is that we there's
a lot of there's 5,000 licensed places
that we have we don't get to as as often
as we could let alone farmers markets is
is some way of building in those those
protections um because it sounds like um
you know as best as we've tried to make
some decisions trying to um look at risk
and and allow lowrisk Foods is that
we're still missing the mark As far as
either people aren't um abiding by that
or they're not labeling things correctly
is is that there we're still missing the
mark somehow so that's just one thought
that we have kind of bounced around as a
as an idea of maybe how something could
work
but okay Addie yeah I want to talk about
two things and one is just a response to
that um the state that we used to live
in Virginia has a very Rob robust
homebased food producer system um where
you can make refrigerated items you can
basically do anything you could do in a
commercial kitchen you can do in your
home kitchen as long as you're labeling
it correctly um and the reason that they
have that is because they have an
extensive um inspection system for
homebased food producers as well as
extensive
like uh resources to help them be safe
so it might be worth looking at some of
those resources that Virginia already
has because they have food safety stuff
that is tailored to the home producer
which can be kind of different from the
restaurant um producer so that's one
thing um the second thing is kind of
about the importance of homebased
industry um I kind of wanted to tell a
little bit very short story about my
background um so my great-grandmother
immigrated to the US from Bellar Russia
uh in around 1900 she did not speak any
English she didn't read or right she
spoke only Yiddish she live she met my
great-grandfather who was a ragman and
if you don't know what that is it's
someone who carries a sack of rags and
sells them on the street and so he would
like ride the trolleys around Pittsburgh
and sell these Rags uh she and her
sister took in like mending and also did
baked goods from their home my
grandmother her daughter was the first
person to graduate from high school in
the family and she took like an
accounting course and then did as sort
of side work while her husband was in
the military accounting from their
kitchen table in the evenings to bring
in extra money my mom went to law school
and she ended up quitting her corporate
job so that she could stay home and also
while doing her law career be with me
and take care of me when I was
little being able to
produce money and income for your family
from resources that you already have at
home is like a Cornerstone of the
American dream and of economic Mobility
so I think that should also be
considered when you're you're thinking
about this bill it's not just about pies
it's not just about Refrigeration it's
not just about you know Local Foods it's
also about do families in this state
have the ability to move upwards
economically and do they have the
ability to do things that don't require
you know college or don't require Long
training programs that they won't have
to work at McDonald's for the rest of
their lives because they can take
something that they're good at and that
they want to improve upon and actually
benefit from that labor so I hope you'll
consider that as well I
sure go
ahead we can sell the products yeah I
just want like seriously we just want to
be able to make money doing the things
that we're doing and not have to go back
to like working minimum wage because
that's why you get paid as a line follow
up Mr chair followup sure the reason I
suggested the term Artisan versus home
stead is because persons well many um
producers are not home steuding they're
not growing their own foods and
processing them and selling them you
could be in an apartment in Manchester
making cupcakes but you're not
homesteading and the term Artisan uh is
very much in use in marketing these days
and
um it is also being used here in New
Hampshire by the conquered farmers
market that wants to promote farmers and
Artisans um Canan farmers market and
Artisans is how it's
advertised uh wilmet Farmers Market
features The
Artisans
and this is what many people Express to
me that they want to be called that they
are producing um
not a high school you know baking
experiment it is quality handmade and
that's what Artisan means handmade um
Foods so not everybody lives on a farm
or can relate to the term
Homestead uh I had boasted that I had
not found that term used through the
Secretary of State um uh name
registration
[Music]
uh in advertising Google searching until
I met Miss
Paulson whose company is called yummy
cupcakes and at the top of her card it
says Homestead
kitchen so that kind of blew my um uh
assertion out of the
water and I asked Miss Paulson I said if
we were able to change the term to
Artisan would it be a financial burden
to change your marketing material
and and would you be in favor of the
term Artisan over Homestead so if she
could
respond
sure thank you uh my response was
initially I felt a sense of uh belonging
in my Homestead title because the
product was coming from my home I do
appreciate the elevation of becoming an
artisan uh producer within my Artisan
home kitchen because again I believe
that we could Elevate what the state of
New Hampshire has to offer within its
tourism within its local
communities and in The Duality of
artisan and potentially a New Hampshire
seal of approval I think that you could
essentially get a gold star when folks
are coming into our state and
stopping along Route 4 or
101 wherever they may be and finding a
market that has a Artisan product with
an Hampshire seal of approval that
they've met standards for safety and Etc
uh
so
I believe that the Improvement to
Artisan uh would benefit
the state the bill and the producers
finding happy ground for the
farm I don't know that someone who is
producing
um something with their beef I I don't
recall exactly what you mentioned but I
don't know that they want to come away
from that Homestead aspect and I think
that would be a question of how many
farmers exist within what we are
currently considering that Homestead um
but in terms of the products the the
pies the hummus the cupcakes um I would
approve and appreciate U being elevated
to
Artisan interesting okay Miss Smith I I
would uh I would Advocate not moving
away from Artisan just because I I feel
like there's already so much confusion
around home the around home Foods is
changing the terminology just might add
to the confusion plus I don't think it
could limit I mean you could be a small
producer in a in a shop and make an
artisan food it wouldn't necessarily
limit you to being a home food producer
with that terminology and whereby you
generally Most states refer to it as a
homestead or Cottage Foods Artisan I
think would it might create confusion as
to
that it's meant to be in a home kitchen
setting that would that's just my just
just in hearing the challenges that
we've had around Homestead regulations
is I I think it might just create
confusion while I think it's very well
intentioned and I understand the need
for an elevation and elevation and
terminology I I I would just caution
about changing the terminology with what
people are have been familiar with for
for many many
years you may thank you madam chair um
it is a 50/50 split for me because I
would like to accommodate our Farmers
within that and the
homestead
um Elevate to an artisan or leave me at
Homestead and give me a New Hampshire
seal of approval something that we can
bring forward to just bolster the system
bolster what the products that can be
offered if we can get those pies out
there and get give us more freedom um
loosen what the law currently has but
find
potentially a course uh whether it's an
online CBT which is dreaded my career as
well I'm familiar uh but it it is an
easy access way
to have a bit more oversight if we're
loosening opening the door door to more
freedom okay all right thank you Mr
Williams just wanted to add something a
little bit you know the the example I
mentioned earlier where I can produce
TCS food safely with a $2,000
refrigerator in my home kitchen as
opposed to spending $100,000 building a
commercial kitchen um I think that
speaks to the economic Mobility my wife
mentioned um right now we can we can buy
a $2,000 refrigerator
but I don't have $100,000 to spend on
that kitchen I either have to go into
significant debt in order to do that
which I'd have to use my our property to
secure and I I can speak about debt
destroying small businesses I've watched
it happen many times but the point is I
want that commercial kitchen because
it's going to be more efficient and work
better a a purpose design commercial
kitchen is much easier to work in
producing commercial quantities of food
than a home kitchen that's been adapted
for sure I want to build that kitchen if
I if if the law allows me to make TCS
Foods in that home kitchen with the
commercial equipment added then I have a
stepping stone to that I can use that to
raise that
$100,000 and buy that new kitchen for
cash instead of going into debt so my
business becomes more viable so that we
have one more small business in New
Hampshire where 98 cents on every dollar
someone spends stays in New Hampshire so
there's there's like an enormous
incentive to allow this and I definitely
understand wanting to control the way
it's done so that it's safe and it's not
willy-nilly but um you know perhaps we
don't mess with our Homestead
regulations so we create a new category
of artisan foods and add it on and if
somebody because somebody can be doing
artist and be doing something a little
bit
different I I I mean I suppose that's a
possibility because again yeah there's
definitely people who want to stick with
that Homestead thing there's definitely
a a connotation there's a subtext to
Homestead as opposed to Artisan that
communicates something and again from
your standpoint just changing the name
on everything suddenly creates a lot of
confusion and especially if you then
change some of the rules now you've got
a whole another layer of confusion to
deal with but if you don't change this
and just add something add a capability
that is allowed allow a new thing that
is pretty simple and
straightforward representative kto thank
you madam chair I want to address a
question to you
um what would you see legislation
looking like in order for you to do the
stepping stone um in order for you to
not be to have some commercial equipment
but not be a commercial kitchen um and
getting that Comm to get to that next
level so just an idea to be honest I
think it's pretty simple um the uh
engineering requirements for commercial
grade refrigeration and commercial
appliances is extremely well- defined
it's not if you go to say
restaurantsupply.com or webstaurant and
you search for commercial
equipment that if it says commercial on
that website it meets the standard that
is extremely well enforced it is
extremely organized everyone understands
it that needs to and then there are also
very there are already requirements
built into the code for how commercial
equipment is powered it has to be on its
own circuit it has to have this type of
breaker it has to be GFI all that stuff
already exists it's not that hard to do
so you would just first off there is
language um that prohibits the use of
commercial equipment in home kitchens
just get rid of it just get rid of it
and then apply when people do put
commercial equipment in you just apply
the same requirements for that equipment
that you would in a commercial kitchen
it's not that complicated um you know
wiring is wiring um you know wi you know
Breakers are Breakers um you know uh I'd
be I'd say that like I don't necessarily
think there's that much to gain by
requiring air gap plumbing and
handwashing stations and all like some
of the stuff that is required for a
commercial kitchen stainless steel work
surfaces that stuff is really
expensive stainless steel work surfaces
only stay sanitary if you sanitize them
properly anyway
um so I think some of the requirements
there are some requirements that are
more important than others I guess is
what I'm saying for food safety and
Refrigeration is like number one like
that is the most important safety
equipment in any kitchen yeah well and
training um which for us isn't an issue
but like if you have employees making
sure that there is some sort of food
handler certification which already
exists that is I think pretty
reasonable
so what prevents you from becoming a
commercial
kitchen hold on no no no I'm I'm not
asking why you're not a I I'm not
talking about dollars I'm talking about
as you add commercial
equipment what then disqualifies you
from being the commercial kitchen when
when you've already upped your standards
so I'm just going to I'm playing devil's
advocate here so you've upped your
standards you've increased your uh
capacity uh to make foods because you've
added commercial equipment
Etc how do you differentiate you being a
homestead versus a commercial from
everybody else so I'm just I'm just
talking
about you know when do you get when do
you get to be the commercial kitchen you
know what is the requirement when do you
step over that line
I mean because we've eliminated the
dollar amount on what you can sell from
your home so basically what I'm saying
is if you had all the commercial
equipment in your home then technically
you would be a commercial kitchen
without without any dollar limits so I'm
just trying to find out where that how
we differentiate and I'm not advocating
one way or the other I'm just asking I I
actually um I think there's two aners to
this one um if we're building a kitchen
from scratch there are a lot there's
this a long list of requirements that
you know what kind of materials are on
your walls um what kind of insulation
you can use um what kind of how many
candles of lighting you have in your
storage there's a lot of details that go
into that that are way above and beyond
what you can even do in a home kitchen
so I think um for one it's going to be
really easy to differentiate from if
you're an inspector between someone's
home kitchen that has commercial
equipment um and an actual like groundup
commercial kitchen um the other thing
um uh is
that you know why why do we need to have
a distinction between my kitchen and a
commercial kitchen if the food is safe
why like what what is the point of
having a distinction
um yeah just a side note that you know
we're hearing about this one their
particular situation but if we do allow
the homestead food you know situation to
grow we're going to be actually growing
the commercial kitchen um business as
well because if someone's on a small
scale and they're starting to have
success at a farmers market and then
they pick up another one they're not
just going to try and make more and more
food food from their kitchen eventually
they're going to want to go out so if if
he if they're saying there's you know
$100,000 uh you know entry fee into that
business other people that already
operate commercial kitchens are GNA want
to open another one or other PE people
are a smart person is going to say why
do I want to get into the food business
what I could get into the commercial
kitchen business you know like so you
know if we open this up a little bit I
think we'll see growth in uh that
industry for sure oh I I absolutely
agree I mean we've looked into buying
some commercial appliances and it's like
if we do that and if I ever wanted to do
Homestead then I'm disqualified so I
understand exactly where you're coming
from I'm just trying to look at it from
all sides so um we've like struggled
with ways to kind of regulate scale and
the first bill I worked on we got rid of
the dollar thing so so now it's like
what are we going to do regulate the
size of your fridge like that's what
we're doing kind I know it's it's a
little bit
weird
um I just wanted to speak to that
question as well I think anyone who's
making food out of their home either
wants to stay a manageable size within
their home or they want to graduate to a
purpose-- driven space I don't think
there are of people who would
voluntarily just run a commercial
kitchen for the rest of their lives out
of their kitchen because it is horrible
there's like butter completely filling
your fridge so you can't put your like
normal meal stuff in there it's like
it's a I mean it's a nightmare from like
a living standards perspective because
you're always prioritizing the business
over your own standard so the goal is
always I think for people who want to
produce a lot of food to get to the
point where you can afford that that
beautiful shiny space where there's
refrigerators and there's extra ovens
and there's you know an ice maker
instead of having to like go to the
store in the morning to get the ice and
like make sure there's actually room in
your freezer for the bag of ice and all
of that so there is there is that um and
then there's also something that's
already pretty much built into the law
as it exists now um which is that
homebased kitchens are producing
packaged Foods versus producing um like
hot held catering food and that's
already in the statute so I don't think
that changing to being able to make um
TCS packaged Foods is going to get you
into a situation where you'll have
people running little restaurants from
their homes although technically that is
kind of legal with the occasional Food
Service establishment stuff already so I
I don't think there's really a conflict
there okay
thanks and speaking to that yes uh I
currently go to my market and I bring
anywhere from 10 to 12 dozen cupcakes um
which
are certainly elevated compared to the
standard cupcake and I sell out most of
the time my kitchen is limited under the
law and therefore uh my ability to grow
is stunted currently if I could bring in
a commercial refrigerator to allow me to
keep more volume of butter my shortening
is stable it sits on the Shelf my eggs I
need a space to do that I have my family
knows and this is a a little inside bit
my family knows that the beginning of
December that first week after
Thanksgiving the shopping stops because
I need my refrigerator for eggs butter
and buttermilk because I'm going to
a city tree lighting that has requested
42 dozen cupcakes for
one8 hour period And I pulled it off
last year for the first time and they
asked me back if I had that ability to
have one more
refrigerator I
could I could Elevate myself so
that's so so what I'm hearing
I mean DHHS probably won't like it but
if we could just remove the word
commercial appliances from the
statute that might solve a lot of the
issues that we're sitting here hearing
um um Madam
chair I would suggest instead of just
removing no commercial equipment you
could say any equipment that you can
effectively like sanitize wash sanitize
um and store would be kind of a better
language because it would any equipment
that you can
effectively um wash and sanitize because
I think one of the concerns that DHHS
has put um has sort of put in their
materials is that a lot of commit
commercial kitchen stuff is bigger so
it's harder to wash in your home sink um
so just putting something on there so
that it's you know you can't use a
mixing bowl that's like bigger than your
ability to clean it um um is kind of an
important thing but just speaking to the
the commercial refrigeration and the
commercial equipment having a ban on
commercial equipment in Homestead food
operations actually makes it harder to
be safe because you can't use the NSF
stuff that is certified to be really
easy to clean or you're not supposed to
um and it's also really it's not really
enforceable it's not like DHHS can come
into your house anyway and look for it
unless they suspect a problem and so it
really punishes people who are volunt
following the law instead of the people
who are just like yeah I'm going to
break the law because no one can check
so why even have it in there if it's
going to punish the people who you want
to have making food because they want to
do it
safely I really like this yeah you like
to and I I really so I think I think
where we're we're maybe going a little
bit off track is is that commercial
kitchen commercial equipment isn't
required and I think it also speaks to
when people bring in like an industrial
siiz mixer that's leads to other that
leads to the other problems and and also
people are bound by space not everyone
has space to have a walk-in cooler in
their house it it's not that we're
Banning commercial equipment it's not
commercial equipment isn't required it
says on your website that it is banned
yeah it's prohibits not say and I I
think when we're not I think we're
looking at where it's the it's the
equipment so again it's going to your
Hobart mixers these large industrial
siiz mixers or steam kettles like we
these weren't these are it's not
standard um home equipment so I I don't
want to create Confusion by saying we're
opposed to someone adding a piece of
equipment like a refrigerator that's
going to allow them to produce food
safety so we are allowed to do that
because it says it says on your website
that you can't use commercial equipment
that's what we've all been operating
under the idea of that is absolutely
true because we've thought about getting
a commercial refrigerator and it's just
you can't if you want to do Homestead so
I think it's becoming to the point where
the homestead food operation was
designed to it had it like inherit in
limitations to you weren't supposed to
have a a commercial operation in your
house because people are limited in size
and the idea was you don't want them
going into garage spaces or basement
spaces to add capacity and equipment so
if there's if we can you know certainly
have discussions offline if there's
something you know we're not we're not
going we're not in the habit of making a
a situation unsafe just because of
crafting out language but but I think
where we're going down the road is it's
it's the installing commercial equipment
could lead to other problems and also
we're looking at the inherent footprint
of what a home kitchen is designed to do
I I don't want to like Spiral down to a
rabbit hole but there can be other there
could be un other intendent consequences
certainly your septic capacity is is
another thing that if you did have a
commercial operation you would be
required to have a an aseptic system
that's sized appropriately if you're
having a baking operation that where you
are bringing in extra Refrigeration
extra ovens extra mixers certainly you
might that you might have other
unintended consequences from that
operation okay one more
one more comment and I think you know
we've already run over time and I don't
want to keep everybody here all
afternoon um possibly we may have um
another
meeting um to discuss possibilities for
uh a bill for next year or something um
so i' just like to kind of let Addie
speak and then kind of wrap it up if
that's okay with
everyone um I just wanted to say that
the idea that
because it's your home kitchen it's too
small to produce a lot of food is kind
of it's kind of something someone who's
never worked in a restaurant would say
because every restaurant that I've ever
worked in was a lot smaller the kitchen
space was a lot smaller than our home
kitchen and our home kitchen is not big
like I'm talking you can crank out food
for
like 120 people in like a very small
period of time from a station that's as
big as this not even this whole table
like this two-piece table it's not hard
you just have to be organized and you
just have to work hard and like be very
precise and think a lot about your menu
and what you're going to serve so the
idea that there's some
inherent cap on what you can do in a
home kitchen is kind of it's not really
true and so it's not really part of what
the law even says now because there
isn't a cap on it it's like you can do
what you can do in your home kitchen so
if you're good at it you should be able
to produce a bit of food and there's no
reason not to if you're doing it safely
as far as we're concerned the two main
considerations are the fact that it's
very clear that commercial equipment is
prohibited if we could clear that up
that would be great and also being able
to produce at least some TCS Foods out
of a homestead kitchen and if there are
extra requirements on you know that
kitchen on training all that stuff is
totally reasonable but just being able
to have the option again going back to
what the market is looking for people
some people are interested in whole raw
ingredients far more people
overwhelmingly more people are looking
for prepared foods and in order to have
a viable food-based
business we are very limited in our
ability to do that if we cannot sell
them prepared
foods at
some okay all right well I want to thank
everybody for taking the time to come
and have these discussions very
important um to hear um you know what
the needs and desires are versus uh you
know what our
current statutes require or make make U
appropriation for um and I think we need
to you know continue continue having
these kinds of discussions to really um
solve some of the issues
that our food producers have been
experiencing and um so again I want to
thank everybody for taking the time to
come as we you know sort of work through
some of these issues and try and come up
with some solutions for the people of
New Hampshire and um in our business
small businesses and our homesteaders
our Artisans whatever we want to call
ourselves um so thank you very much and
I will uh let everybody know
uh when we may have an another meeting
for this but um thank you again for your
time e